Tak co je vlastně Qiskit
Qiskit je open source sada nástrojů pro vývoj softwaru
pro práci s kvantovými počítači
na úrovni circuit
algoritmů a aplikačních modulů tato sada
umožňuje každému programovat na skutečných kvantových počítačích z
vlastního laptopu na dvou řádcích kódu máš přístup
k několika kvantovým systémům od supravodivých
až po qubit v iontové pasti chceš emulovat chování kvantového počítače
místo toho změň jeden řádek kódu
a simuluj své quantum circuit na našem vysokovýkonném
simulátoru Qiskit je nástroj používaný desítkami
tisíc lidí po celém světě kteří se snaží
budovat budoucnost ať už jsi výzkumník vývojář
nebo si jen chceš začít
Qiskit má celou řadu
funkcí dostupných pro tvé potřeby
které každému umožní dělat věci jako
sestavit svůj první quantum circuit
spouštět mezidoménové kvantové algoritmy
a studovat základní kvantové jevy
možná je teď ten správný čas zapojit se sám
a najít všechny nástroje které potřebuješ
včetně skutečných kvantových strojů
a SDK přes Qiskit
a komunitu která tě ráda přivítá
a zodpoví jakékoli otázky které tě cestou napadnou
můžeš začít ještě dnes
na Qiskit